on the internet you'll find scammers who
show off their massive bank account
balances while they try to sell you a
course on how you can get there too
but there's actually an easier way to
grow your bank account open up the
browser console with ctrl shift j
then execute this line of code to turn
the document's design mode on
we can now modify any text in the web
page itself like the bank account
balance
as developers we tend to take a lot of
technologies for granted one of which is
the web browser
not only is it one of the most important
technologies for all of humanity but
modern browsers contain all kinds of
awesome developer tools that were
unimaginable 10 years ago
in today's video we'll look at a ton of
features and tricks in your browser's
dev tools that you probably didn't know
exist and will make your life much
easier as a web developer
first like and subscribe to keep this
content coming then add your own pro tip
to the comments and i'll pick one of
them to win this free t-shirt next week
i'm going to focus on chrome dev tools
in this video but firefox also has an
awesome suite of dev tools and most of
the tricks i'll show you
apply to both browsers and if you use
edge or brave they're both based on
chromium so everything applies there as
well
and if you use safari or internet
explorer may god help you
first we need to open up the console
which we can do with the ctrl shift j
shortcut what you may not know
is that chrome has a command palette
just like vs code that you can access
with control p
type an angle bracket and that will give
you a list of every command
at your disposal in the dev tools a
useful one especially if you want to
show off your bank account
is screenshot which allows you to
screenshot an entire page
a custom area or an individual dom node
but if we go ahead and open up the
command palette again
you'll notice it provides a big list of
files these files are the actual html
css
javascript and images loaded by this
webpage
when you click on one it takes you to
the sources tab where you can actually
edit and inspect the file
in production it's likely minified so
click the pretty print button to make it
look nicer but here's something you
didn't know
in the bottom right corner you'll see
the option for coverage which will bring
up the coverage panel and this will tell
you exactly how much your javascript or
css is contributing to the visual
elements on this page
red bars indicate unused or dead code
that may be making your app slower
you might want to go verify that that
code is actually required in your
production bundle
now if you want to execute some
javascript code in the browser you can
do that from the console
you'll likely be using a command like
document query selector to grab an
element from the dom
but web developers have always felt that
that's way too much code
instead use a dollar sign just like
jquery as an alias of document query
selector
or grab multiple elements with a double
dollar sign like query selector all
or if you happen to have something
selected in the elements tab use dollar
sign 0 to grab the current element
once you've grabbed an element you may
want to see how its value changes over
time
you could execute the same line of code
over and over again but a smarter option
is to click on the eye icon to pin it to
the console as a live expression where
it will automatically update every time
the application state changes
in some cases though you may want to run
more complex code open the command
palette and create a new snippet you can
write whatever javascript code you'd
like here
then when you open up the command
palette again and type a bang it'll be
there
ready for you to execute whenever you
need it that's pretty cool but one thing
that can be kind of annoying
is that when you're messing around in
the console you might want to redeclare
the same variable over and over again
using const with the same name twice
would normally produce an error but in
the chrome console it's no problem
because we're just messing around here
javascript is one thing but more often
than not i'm using the browser dev tools
to debug my html and css if i'm
illegally scraping a website i might
want to go to their html
and copy an element into my own project
i could just copy the element with ctrl
c
or i can right click and get a variety
of different copy options an especially
useful one
is copy selector because i can then use
it to target an element in my css or
javascript or if i really like the way
an element looks i can copy its styles
and paste them directly in my css when
you click on an element in the dom
it will show you all of the css styles
that apply to it in the styles tab
but what if you want to see the styles
when an element is hovered or focused
you can do that by right-clicking an
element
or from the styles panel you'll see the
hov button
to force an element state that'll cause
the element to stay frozen in that state
making it easier to inspect that css
that's useful for simple transitions but
you might also
have complex animations on a page the
animations panel allows you to record
any keyframe animations that are
happening on the screen you can scrub
them back and forth slowly and inspect
the actual css properties that they
affect and is really useful for
understanding how animations work on
other impressive web pages
however if you go too crazy with your
animations it may slow down the
rendering of the webpage
causing jank and just an uncomfortable
user experience the rendering panel is
like a heads up display that helps you
detect a variety
of different issues before they become a
problem if we check the box for frame
rendering stats it will provide data
about the frames per second
and the total memory used on the gpu now
css is awesome and all but the best kind
of code
is the code that you don't have to write
if you're working with flexbox or
gridlayout
go to the layout tab and draw visual
markers around those elements by
checking the boxes that you want to see
back in the styles tab if you go to the
display property and its value is
flexbox or grid
you'll see an icon that you can click on
that brings up a dialog where you can
modify the layout without having to
memorize a bunch of confusing css
properties and there's also a similar
tool for box shadows which are
notoriously difficult to code by hand
but if you'd rather modify your website
with something more like an actual
design tool check out the viz bug
extension it allows you to interact with
the web page itself and modify its
appearance without knowing or
understanding css whatsoever now your
design may look good on your machine but
how do you know it's responsive to
different screen sizes
you can find out by clicking on the
device toolbar it provides a bunch of
common screen sizes to choose from or
you can use the responsive option to
resize it yourself manually and you can
even throttle the network speed here to
simulate low end devices
but the fun doesn't stop there if you're
targeting mobile devices that use
geolocation or motion you can simulate
things like gps coordinates and device
acceleration and motion
from the sensors panel if you're
targeting mobile users then you're
likely building a progressive web app
the lighthouse tool will analyze your
website
for performance search engine
optimization and progressive web app
features
if you pass the audit it means your
website can be installed on a mobile
device just like a native app and if you
fail the audit it will tell you exactly
what you need to address in order to
make the experience for mobile users
better one of the most common issues is
that a website is slow to paint the
initial content and that's usually
because it tries to load too much
javascript and css you can inspect
exactly how the browser loads all of
your assets by going to the network tab
it creates a waterfall graphic that
shows every request the browser makes
and how long it takes to fetch each one
of those assets
if you're worried about performance turn
on screenshots to see how your website
loads after each request is completed
clicking on an individual item will
provide a breakdown of the response body
and headers
and if you want to dive really deep into
performance click on the timing panel
it'll show you exactly how long it took
to fetch something
breaking down the timing all the way to
the dns level what you didn't know
though
is that there's actually a server timing
api that allows you to pass more
detailed information
from your server to the browser when the
server timing header is present on a
response
chrome will automatically break that
information down in the browser dev
tools for the end user there are four
main issues when it comes to performance
response animation idle and load
lighthouse and the network panel can
help you debug
loading issues but for the other three
we'll need to analyze the actual runtime
performance of our code which we can do
in the performance panel hit the record
button
then start using your site like an end
user when you end the recording
it'll give you a breakdown of the cpu
usage frames per second
and the amount of memory allocated to
the heat if you notice a spike in cpu
usage
a drop in frames per second or a jump in
memory usage
it might indicate an area of code that
needs to be optimized to investigate
further chrome has generated a flame
chart
that breaks down everything that happens
on the browser's main thread
in other words this is how the browser
executes your javascript step by step
the x-axis represents time
and the y-axis is the call stack if the
chart is really tall
it's not much of a problem you might
just be calling deeply nested functions
but if a frame is really wide it means
that something is taking a long time
in which case you should click on it to
investigate why your code sucks in more
detail
now in some cases the main thread might
be fine but your code might create a
memory leak by allocating memory to
objects that you no longer need
you can tell you have a memory leak when
this blue line gets bigger and bigger
but to investigate it further let's head
over to the memory tab select the option
for
allocation instrumentation then hit the
record button when it's done
the blue bars indicate memory that is
still in use while the gray bars
indicate memory that was garbage
collected
at any point in time you can see every
object that's currently allocated to the
heap it can be sorted by size allowing
you to figure out exactly which objects
are clogging up your memory
and there you have 21 techniques to try
out and chrome dev tools
but here's one more bonus tip to leave
you with if you like chrome dev tools
then you'll also like brave browser
they don't pay me to say that it's just
the browser that i use for most of my
personal work
it's based on chromium so all of the
devtools are exactly the same
and the ceo of the company is none other
than brendan eick the inventor of
javascript
but most importantly it's privacy
focused with built-in ad blocking
capabilities and when it does show ads
you actually get paid to see them that's
pretty awesome
but i'm going to go ahead and wrap
things up there hit the like button and
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one